well months ago we brought you this
story of a double amputee veteran on the
brink of homelessness after his
caretaker allegedly stole thousands of
dollars from him but our reporting has
finally helped Richard Romano get housed
Ryan mathie shows us the success story
and the increasing difficulty for others
like him to have the same outcome
yeah well then you
this was 81 year old Richard Romano back
in November debating if he would sue his
previous caretaker the man he claimed
stole nearly five thousand dollars from
him leading to his eventual eviction he
barely knows how to get to the storage
let alone I live on the streets his
friend Richard Stevens helped to keep
him off the streets for months plean on
social media for anyone to take him in
and using his own money to get him by
after our previous stories on Romano
aired U.S vets took notice and months
after his first eviction he now calls
one of these apartments his home the U.S
vets saying his story is not too
uncommon you come in we get you housed
we set you up you're on your own next
the veteran connected to U.S vets lead
and case manager Trista Dowd we are
seeing a lot more
veterans experiencing homelessness and
our numbers and as far as our program
goes are increasing daily the booming
cost to live in Las Vegas she says is
one reason why along with growing rent
prices high security deposits and
increasing opposition from landlords to
take them in people who are 50 60 70 80
years old might have some skeletons in
the closet like evictions like felonies
that we need to be able to be
understanding and compassionate about
and being able to work around that but
this man's story giving hope that it is
possible the man deserves to have good
rest of his years however many that
maybe hopefully many
because it's like
where he is now and where he was my God
it's like I can actually see the light
great follow-up there Ryan Matthey the
case manager says they're covering his
first three months of rent and the
security deposit now she adds each of
the six case managers just in that one
office work with up to 30 clients at one
time